siempre me han gustado las artesanías
sus colores texturas y formas me dejan
maravillada y más cuando descubro que
tienen sus sesiones por todos lados esta
es parte del decorado de una blusa que
compré hace poco en un mercado de
artesanías aquí encontramos sucesiones
aritméticas y sucesiones geométricas
vamos a descubrirlas y analizarlas
juntos primero descomponga mos nuestra
figura empecemos por las flores aquí
vemos que las flores van aumentando
primero tenemos una luego tenemos 4
después 7 y enseguida 10 numéricamente
la sucesión se escribiría de la
siguiente manera 1 4 7 10 este tipo de
sucesión es aritmética porque cada vez
que aparece un grupo de flores se
agregan 3 más veamos en la figura 1
tenemos 1 igual a 1 + 0 igual a 1 en la
figura 2 tenemos 13 4
en la figura 3 tenemos 4 3 7 y en la
figura 4 son 73 igual a 10
recuerda que las progresiones
aritméticas tienen un patrón que suma o
resta un valor determinado al último
término de una sucesión en este caso el
valor constante es el número 3 ahora
analicemos la otra figura y determinemos
el tipo de sucesión que tenemos en ella
vamos a contar los cuadritos de cada
figura para encontrar el patrón y el
valor constante que se repite en cada
figura contemos de la izquierda a la
derecha la primera figura es un rombo la
segunda tiene 3 la tercera 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 y 9
la cuarta 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 y
numéricamente la sucesión quedaría así
13 9 y 27 interesante si revisamos la
sucesión encontramos nuevamente el
número 3 como valor constante pero como
si uno más tres no son tres es porque lo
estamos multiplicando ya te fijaste
vamos a revisar la figura paso a paso en
la primera figura tenemos uno vamos a
multiplicarlo por tres y nos da tres que
son los rombos de la segunda figura
ahora tres lo multiplicamos por tres y
el resultado es 9 y finalmente 9 lo
multiplicamos por 3 y me da 27 la cuarta
y última figura así se obtiene la
sucesión 13 927 la representación
numérica de esta sucesión geométrica
sería la siguiente figura 1 igual a 1 en
la figura 2 es igual a 1 por 3 3 la
figura 3 sería 3 por 39 y por último en
la figura 4 igual
9 por 3 27 este sencillo ejercicio nos
permitió conocer con mayor claridad la
diferencia entre una sucesión aritmética
y una geométrica te presento el decorado
de un vestido y te invito a descubrir
otros patrones y sucesiones en él